and what i can tell you this morning is
that as a result firstly of the
information
provided by the cabinet office inquiry
team
and secondly my office's own assessment
i can confirm
that the met is now investigating
a number of events that took place at
downing street and whitehall
in the last two years
in relation to potential breaches of
curvit-19 regulations
my officers have assessed several other
events
that appear to have taken place at
downing street and whitehall
on the available information these other
events
are assessed as not reaching the
threshold for criminal investigation
i now call the prime minister
prime minister
thank you mr speaker mr speaker a few
weeks ago i commissioned an independent
inquiry into a series of events in
downey street in the cabinet office as
well as some other whitehall departments
that may have constituted potential
breaches of the covid regulations that
process has quite properly involved
sharing information continuously with
the metropolitan police so i welcome the
mets decision to conduct its own
investigation because i believe this
will help to give the public the clarity
it needs and help to draw a line under
matters but i want to reassure the house
mr speaker and the country that i and
the whole government are focused 100
on dealing with the people's priorities
including the uk's leading world role in
protecting freedom around the world
well i don't know it's taken so long
there's been so many controversies so
far and hasn't kicked him out of office
so um it's a bit of a teflon pm at the
moment so
i don't know they have to take one hell
of a scandal to get them out i think
sort of like
it's more of the same isn't it it's like
i don't expect any more from him to be
honest i think everybody's expectations
are totally at its low lowest step at
the moment um they probably always have
been well for me anyway i've never
expected any more from him totally
disappointed
well to be honest it's like you say if
you break the rules you've got to go in
here there's too many excuses i've been
coming from him
do you know everything's an excuse and
that apology the other day that's like
insulting all our intelligence really
isn't it like if he thinks all that dumb
that we're going to believe what he said
yeah i'll be honest i always vote for
boris but he's got to go in it he broke
the rules you've got to go i think the
people who organize the party are still
culpable
and it's just one thing after another
really and i think the excuses have run
dry really